ist das so herr lindemann die erste
gigantische fehleinschätzung hat die
regierung schon getätigt bevor sie
überhaupt regierung ist ja das schlimme
an der ganzen sache ist glaube ich dass
sie sich so viel zeit lässt das hat ja
dann glaube ich zwei drei wochen
gedauert bis man sich getroffen hat die
ministerpräsidenten und auch herr scholz
man hatte das gefühl er liest den text
ab über das thema corona und dann
beginnt die ampel sache ich will jetzt
nicht gleich als oppositionspolitiker
drauf hauen aber es fällt schon auf dass
die ganzen corona themen in der ganzen
sache nicht nur im wahlkampf sondern
auch danach bei den vereinbarungen
irgendwie nicht so ernst genommen wurde
wie man es hätte nehmen müssen wir
bleiben hier nochmal bei der viele
einschätzung mit sie habe gerade schon
gesagt sie sind ja nicht er spreche hier
von olaf scholz deswegen schauen wir was
die eigenen reihen was die fdp gesagt
hat ihr kollege marco buschmann auch er
ist gerade mal zwei wochen her
das ist nicht in einzelnen lokalen
gegebenheiten auch zu einer belastung
auch in krankenhäusern kommt dass da
auch ärzte und pflegepersonal unter
hoher belastung stehen aber es droht
unserer festen überzeugung nach keine
systemische überlastung des öffentlichen
gesundheitssystems mehr und deshalb
nehmen wir jetzt einen überschaubaren
katalog niedrigschwelliger und auch
wenig eingriffs intensiver maßnahmen und
stellen sie zur verfügung dort wo man
sie braucht aber auch das nicht mit
offenem ende wie bei der alten regelung
sondern es gibt ein absolutes ende aller
maßnahmen und alle maßnahmen enden
spätestens mit dem frühlingsbeginn am 20
märz
sind die ihnen hätte er diese worte
mittlerweile unangenehm das muss das
ziel bleiben und ich will zum
infektionsschutzgesetz darum ging es ja
das ist damals in der
bundespressekonferenz vorgestellt worden
zwei sachen sagen erstens das alte
infektionsschutzgesetz der großen
koalition hat nicht dazu beigetragen die
vierte werde zu verhindern sondern wir
sind sozusagen reingeschlittert über den
sommer ist es erneut nichts passiert
muss man sagen über impfen habe ich
vorhin schon gesprochen mit dieser seite
und da kommen dann an den immer noch
hilfreichen sagt das
infektionsschutzgesetz zu sprechen
kommen testmöglichkeiten sind
eingestellt worden war ein riesenfehler
sieht mittlerweile auch die große
koalition glaube ich so aber das
infektionsschutzgesetz muss sich ja in
zwei dingen messen lassen dass eine
wirksamkeit muss man feststellen dass
alte war nicht wirkt die vierte welle zu
verhindern und zweitens rechtssicherheit
und genau das wollen wir gewährleisten
mit wirksamkeit ganz effektive maßnahmen
auch bis hin zu kontakt beschränkungen
die ja alle im gesetz drin stehen und
vor allem rechtssicher gerade die bayern
müssten lied davon singen die gerichte
haben reihenweise der bayerische
staatsregierung ins stammbuch
geschrieben dass das was sie auf
landesebene aufgrund des alten
bundesgesetzes gemacht haben nicht
grundrechts von konform war und von
daher bin ich mir sicher dass dieses
neue gesetz einerseits effektiver in der
wirksamkeit ist das muss sich jetzt
herausstellen und zum zweiten
rechtssicher ist denn uns bringen keine
gesetze die von gerichten kassiert
werden irgendetwas bei der pandemie
bekämpfen aber um das noch einmal klar
zu machen weil die worte von herrn bush
machen die waren ja auch
unmissverständlich die maßnahmen das war
ja kein ziel sondern das war ein
versprechen die enten im frühjahr
2022 dann wird corona vorbei sein und
viel wichtiger noch aktuell die
einschätzung es droht keine systemische
überlastung der krankenhäuser aber jetzt
fliegen wir von bayern aus dem blume
gebiet patienten nach nordrhein
westfalen nach hamburg das ist ja eine
überlastung der krankenhäuser
fehleinschätzung vor zwei wochen von der
fdp zwei wochen her dynamische situation
heißt aber nicht dass unser ziel bleibt
im kommenden frühjahr die grundrechts
einschränkungen komplett zurückzunehmen
das muss auch das ziel einer
rechtsstaatlichen bundes aber das war
eine fehleinschätzung in bezug auf die
krankenhaus lage das war zu dem
zeitpunkt richtig jetzt haben wir
insbesondere in bayern gehen der flüge
mittlerweile sogar nach norddeutschland
weil die bayerische situation
tatsächlich genauso sachsen übrigen eine
dramatische ist ist es mir nachher weise
ein grund warum ich mir ein bisschen
schwer tue jetzt alle ratschläge aus
bayern und aus münchen zu sehen denn
bisher hat in bayern vor allem eins
nicht geklappt einerseits die testung
aber insbesondere hilft es und sind wir
mehr geimpfte in deutschland stehe ich
auch aber die verlage haben ja wirklich
die sängerin die überlastung des systems
hängt damit zusammen dass wir zurzeit
sehr viel ungeimpfte auf den
intensivstationen haben und das muss
sich ändern deswegen würde ich mir
wünschen dass die bayerische
staatsregierung eine super impfkampagne
ausrollen machen wir ja es stimmt ich
will aber einmal bei dieser
fehleinschätzung bleiben weil sie sagen
zu dem damaligen zeitpunkt war es
richtig dabei herr buschmann hat sich ja
gar nicht auf den damaligen zeitpunkt
bezogen er hat damals gesagt ist droht
also er hat in zukunft gekommen es droht
keine überlastung der krankenhäuser die
haben wir zwei wochen später aber
zumindest in vielen bundesländern wir
haben in einigen bundesländern in
dramatische situation wir haben
bundesweit keine komplett überlastung
des systems und dass das so weit kommt
wollen wir um alles in der welt
natürlich verändern ist doch ganz klar
unter anderem mit dem gesetz weil aber
das ist doch die nächste steuerschätzung
das ist jetzt wirksamer ist herr blume
mit verlaub das alte gesetz der großen
koalition vor allen dingen das gesetz
von ihren sparen und angela merkel hat
uns erst in diese situation gebracht und
ich kann mir mit verlaub die ratschläge
aus münchen nicht so richtig zu eigen
machen denn bitte tun sie einst in
bayern sorgen sie dafür dass mehr
menschen geimpft sind denn dass die
überlastung zur zeit die sie
wahrscheinlich in bayern erleben hängt
damit zusammen dass zu wenig menschen
geimpft sind ich hätte mir gewünscht
bayern nimmt sich ein beispiel an nrw
oder schleswig-holstein wo er wesentlich
effektiver geimpft worden ist und
deswegen blume schwierig was aus bayern
derzeit kommt auch ein wortmeldung von
insel